earlier this season he danced as a  bloody vampire but Monday real blood  might have been spilled  et can't confirm that dancer Alek  skarlatos was taken away in an ambulance  from his Dancing with the Stars  rehearsal on Monday Dancing Pro Emma  Slater accidentally elbowed Alec right  in the face as they rehearsed for  tonight's switch up episode sources tell  ET as of Monday afternoon it was unclear  if Alex knows was broken or not the 23  year old was attended to by doctors and  et can't confirm that he will perform  Monday night Alec and his partner  Lindsey showed sympathy for fellow  contestant Kim Zolciak injury when we  spoke to him just a few weeks ago so sad  because Kim has come so far in this  competition she's such an amazing person